this is where a neighbor said she saw
beata cheaper seven years ago she told
the court she saw the defendant here in
this Dortmund yard with her fellow gang
members and their host a local skinhead
that man says it's a case of mistaken
identity prosecutors were surprised by
the witness who came forward only after
the trial had begun yotsuba she said she
didn't want to draw attention to herself
or to be a busybody she wasn't even sure
that her observations were at all
significant in gavest Harbor the
testimony may have been a blow to
cheaper who prosecutors say took part in
all 10 murders but her attorneys say it
proves nothing it's endless having the
insufficient understate subsequent
investigations by the federal prosecutor
and federal police have confirmed our
views and therefore we're quite relaxed
without indecent plant the evidence
could prove explosive nonetheless if the
witness really did observe what she
claimed they would strongly suggest that
the alleged killers and their
co-defendants didn't act alone but with
the support of a whole network of neo
Nazi sympathizers